it's lonely at the top Michael Williams
is Jamaica's best skier in fact he's the
caribbean nations only Olympic athlete
in that event the canadian-born
frankfurt-based Jamaican hopes to
qualify for Saatchi and has been braving
tough conditions in the Austrian Alps as
he prepares for the games we are serious
about this I mean we spend three to four
hours training every morning we're out
on the slopes from eight in the morning
till about midday and then training
continues indoors stamina training video
analysis and so on training on then
video Hannah loser Williams was inspired
by the famous 1988 jamaican bobsleigh
team the former professional American
football player is in his mid-40s but
still fighting fit nevertheless he still
needs to improve his skills on the piste
to webcam faster make it would be a
dream come true for me to qualify for
the Olympics as a Jamaican skier that
would be just perfect food open- I
desperate absolute perfection William
still has a bit to do to qualify under
the International Ski Federation's rules
but he has his sights firmly set on the
Olympic ski slopes of Sochi